Donald Trump says he wants to speed up
the FDA's drug approval process
yeah Trump said with what I've got
planned America is gonna need all the
drugs it can get Donald Trump also says
that this week this week cuz a lot of
people have been upset about his actions
about refugees well Donald Trump now
says that this week he will allow 872
refugees into the United States 872
specifically yeah yeah Trump says the
immigrants will arrive on Friday and
start their modeling careers on Monday
he's personally a pro you can come in 31
pounds of cocaine have been found hidden
in the nose of an American Airlines jet
authorities became suspicious from the
plane flew from Miami to New York in 16
minutes
we go back another hour and it landed
vertically yeah yeah here's this under
sing the Navy SEAL who actually killed
Osama bin Laden now has a book coming
out yeah yeah here's the word thing it's
a pop-up book goes back down again it's
the dramatic end of the book right there
oh come on you're gonna buy it this is
weird to compete with Amazon today
Walmart started offering free two-day
shipping Walmart free two-day shipping
from Walmart the only problem is no one
wants anything from Walmart to arrive
that fast really you really want it that
quickly
speaking of Amazon this is interesting
Starbucks is partnering with Amazon
Starbucks and Amazon they're partnering
to make it possible for Alexa to place
your coffee order for you yeah all you
have to do is use these simple voice
command Alexa I'm pathetic
oh that's I'm a lazy son of a [ __ ]
you